there are various types of ad formats
that game and app developers can put
into their apps the first and most
familiar to people are banners and
probably the newest that you'll see used
our video ads there's different reasons
you might want to choose each of course
it depends on the type of app but there
are also some other factors what's the
location of most of your users do you
have an in-game economy if you're trying
to offer rewarded videos for instance
you have to take those into accounts
understanding the payouts is a really
important part of understanding your
game monetization strategy so ads pay
according to how the advertiser bids
these completely range understanding all
of these is important because they're
going to determine when you're looking
at your analytics why you are or are not
getting paid and then you can optimize
the ads so that it's a greater
likelihood that somebody's going to
engage with them if it's a cost per
completed view and you're doing a
rewarded video ad then maybe you want to
show your video ads right at the point
where somebody needs whatever say you're
offering an extra life in your game well
you want to show that video ad right
where somebody needs it so that they're
more more likely to complete the view so
you're more likely to get paid if you're
say monetizing from cost per install ads
then you probably don't want to bombard
your users with interstitials pop-up ads
because they're gonna see them
accidentally click on them and then
never install the ad networks themselves
are going to be optimizing based on the
performance of the ads within your app
or game so if they see something that
looks odd or is a really low conversion
rate you're less likely to get ads
served or even high quality ads serve to
your app or game so it's really
important to keep an eye on those
analytics and then work with whoever the
providers are to make sure that you're
delivering the right results finally
when choosing an ad partner it's
important to choose ones that offer
features that you're looking for these
features might be cross promotion so if
you want to have
ad network do double duty for you so
that you can also do things like promote
in-game items or perhaps promote your
next title it's important to choose an
ad network that can satisfy those
objectives another feature that some ad
networks have that people like to choose
from are things like transparency can I
see all of the ads that have been shown
if I have a kids game for instance I
want to make sure that the ads that my
players are seen are age-appropriate if
I have a really sophisticated back-end
that I'm working with I might want to
choose an ad network that has api's that
I can work with perhaps I want to choose
an ad network that functions well with
other elements within my game for
instance if I'm using something like
unity to build my game a development
platform then I want to choose ad
networks that have plugins if I'm using
a mediator
I want to choose ad networks so that I
can then plug into that mediator and
that all work nicely together